你有没有想过那些顶尖交易者的脑袋里到底都在想些什么?
今天我们就来好好的拆解一位市场巨人的思维模式,
看看他是怎么样在这么混乱的市场里找到一条持续获利的路的。
这问题你是不是也想过?
他们是真的有什么水晶球可以预测未来吗?
还是说他们掌握了什么我们一般人都不知道的秘密?
很多人穷尽一身都在追求所谓的交易圣杯
以为只要能预测市场就赢了
但你知道吗
真正的答案竟然是完全相反的方向
也就是管理自己
这就是高手跟我们一般人想的完全不一样的地方
我们今天讲的东西可不是随便乱说的
我们的内容是来自一份非常非常珍贵的资料
就是台湾传奇交易员巨人杰
他本人的私人笔记
这让我们有机会
用一个前所未有的角度
去看看他的思考
到底是怎么走的
在我们深入他的哲学之前
你先看看这个数字
感受一下那个分量
单月
是单单一个月
交易量就达到数百亿
这代表什么
这代表我们接下来要谈的
都不是只上谈兵
而是在真实的战场上
用真金白银验证过的一套铁律
所以巨人节的核心哲学到底是什么
其实讲白了就是这句话
不要再想着当个算命师去预测市场了啦
真正的力量是来自于去控制那些
你唯一能控制的东西
也就是你自己的行为
还有你对几率的掌握
好 那我们就从他2018年的笔记开始看起这也是所有交易心法的第一块基石就是心态巨人节给我们的第一个启示就是把你的放大镜从市场的K线图上移开
转个方向对准你自己
我觉得这句话根本就是交易界的黄金定律
你得先打从先里接受一件事
你一定会犯错
所以真正的决胜点
根本就不在于你猜对几次
而是在你犯错的那个当下
你是恐慌
凹丹
不知所措
还是可以像个冷静的外科医生一样
果断的执行停损
好那研究自己
这听起来很玄
到底是什么意思
其实具体来说就是这几点
第一
你真的要从心底接受你会犯错
接着呢
把你的所有精力都放在设计一个系统
让你在犯错的时候
那个伤害可以降到最低
然后最重要也最难的
就是战胜那种
再等一下下
说不定就涨回来了的人性诱惑
这才是稳定获利的真正系列
好
当你有了稳固的心态
这个地基之后
我们才能来架设那个获利的引擎
在它2019年的笔记里
我们就找到了这个引擎的核心
它是一个很简单
但却完全颠覆一般人想法的数学概念
就是赚赔比远比胜率来的重要
你想想看哦
这背后的数学现实
其实还蛮残酷的
如果你一直追求胜率
你的天花板就是100%
对吧
这是一个几乎不可能达到的数字
但是赚赔比呢
它的潜力理论上是无限的
这代表什么
这就代表你就算错了十次
只要那一次你看对的时候来个惊天动地的大行情就足以扭转乾坤了你看这张图哇这个对比就非常强烈了左边的交易员A
他的胜率高达90%
听起来跟股神一样
对吧
但他最后只赚了50块
右边的交易员B
胜率连一半都不到
只有40%
结果他赚了100块
为什么会这样
答案其实超简单
B在看对的时候
狠狠地赚
看错的时候果断的赔
这就是赚赔比的威力
所以你看
这就点出了高手
跟我们一般人真正的分野在哪了
关键技能
根本就不是谁比较会猜行情
而是在当运气站在你这边
你看对的时候
你有没有那个能力和方法
把这一次的获利放大到极致
但光有心态跟数学
还不够
这就带我们来到最困难
也是最后一块拼图了
这来自他2020年的笔记
执行力
因为就算你什么都懂
如果到最后那个关键时刻
你没有勇气按下那个下单的按钮
那前面的一切都只是纸上富贵而已
这些话是不是听起来超熟悉的
我先买一张试试水温看看好了
等财报出来再说
或是到处问朋友问群主
你觉得这一只股票还会不会涨
这些其实都是源自于
我们内心恐惧的犹豫
而这也正是阻碍
我们获利的最后一道高墙
那巨人节用了一个词
我觉得超传神
来对比这种犹豫
就叫做赚钱的霸气
这不是指你要很傲慢
而是指
当你根据自己的交易系统
发现一个绝佳机会的时候
那种敢于承担风险下定决心冲仓出击的魄力跟自信那这种霸气是天生的吗当然不是它是来自铁一般的纪律
在你要执行的那一刻
你必须把自己
关进一个无声的泡泡里
隔绝掉所有的杂讯
不管是财经新闻
LINE群组的讨论
还是那些专家的报告
因为在那个瞬间
他们唯一的功用
就是动摇你的决心
然后让你跟财富擦肩而过
好了 心态 数学 执行力
这三块拼图我们都拿到了
现在我们把它们拼起来看看
一个顶尖交易者的完整新字模型
究竟长什么样子
你看 这就是巨人节的三维交易模型
心态是地级
它让你能够坦然地面对亏损
数学是引擎
它告诉你怎么样去设计出一套
能够长期获胜的游戏规则
而实行力就是那把点火的腰室
是把前面两者
变成你户头里真实获利的最终行动
这三者少了任何一环
这部赚钱的机器都没办法运转
所以如果要把巨人节枕透
哲学浓缩成一句话
那会是什么
就是这个
交易的本质
它不是一颗可以预测未来的水晶球
它反而像一面镜子
它反映的不是市场的未来
而是你内在的纪律
你的勇气
还有你对几率的理解程度
最后我想留一个问题
让大家回去好好想一想
不只是在交易
可能在你的工作
甚至生活中
你现在花费心力在建立的
是一个试图去猜测
所有未知变数的预测系统
还是一个专注于
在充满不确定性的环境中
做出最佳反应的执行系统呢